With effort to expectation
generation just a while back
let's look into it more deeply.
So when we actually
interact with the world
sometimes things do not happen
the way we expect them to happen.
And sometimes things happen
that people are not expecting.
But how do we know what to expect and
what not to expect?
So consider a situation like this.
This is an instance of a script.
In this particular case,
I have gone to Olive Garden.
And the waiter is Andrew.
So I move to a table and
I sit down at the table.
And now Andrew sees me.
So from my perspective, I am expecting
Andrew to come to me and give me a menu.
But supposing this never happens.
I am sitting there waiting for
Andrew, or someone else, to come, and
no one comes.
That's an expectation violation.
So I know something has gone awry.
The reason I know that is because
I continued expectations using
the scripts,
expectations that are never fulfilled.
Now consider an alternate situation.
Instead of Andrew coming to my table and
giving me a menu, Andrew comes to me and
gives me a bill right away.
Well I should think that I
would be surprised by that.
That was an unexpected
event that occurred.
Well several questions arise here.
First, could this be the beginning
of theory of surprise?
In both cases, we were surprised.
In one case where Andrew did
not come and give a menu.
In the second case, when Andrew came and
gave a bill instead of giving the menu.
On second notice, a surprise,
it has two sides to it.
One, when things do not happen
the way we expect them to happen.
And the other,
when things happen the way in which
we were not expecting them to happen.
This example shows, that scripts not
only tell us what to make sense of
the world around us, they also tell us
what to expect and what not to expect.
And that's a powerful idea.
>> So it seems like another example
where this happens really strongly,
that we encounter fairly frequently,
is if you've ever seen a horror movie.
One thing that horror
movies really do really,
really well is they lure you into
expecting one thing to happen
only to throw something
completely different at you.
So they lure you into kind of a false
sense of security in expecting that
nothing bad is going to happen in a
particular scene, and then suddenly they
throw a ghost at you from offscreen and
it kind of startles you.
And the reason it startles you is
because it violates your expectations
for what were going to happen next.
>> David, that's a good point,
that it happens in many
different kinds of movies.
So when I go and
see a science fiction movie, or
even a romance movie,
I'm expecting certain things to happen.
And sometimes I think a movie is
really good if it is new and novel and
different and
it offers some surprising things.
Notice that this could also be
the beginning of a theory of creativity.
In the last lesson we were
talking about balance and humor.
No we're talking about surprises.
Some current theories of creativity say
that a situation is creative if it is A,
novel, B, if it is useful or
valuable in some way, and
C, if it is unexpected or surprising.
Now, this begins to capture at
least one of those three dimensions
of unexpectedness or surprise,
and that's an important part.
We'll return to computational
creativity at the end of this course,
when we'll talk a lot
more about these issues.